[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
Shad, I thought maybe
we could begin with how you
got started on the investing
journey?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, my father
was in the advertising
business for most of his life,
and he recommended to me that
I buy some Central Airlines
with some money I made in the
summer on a construction job.
So I bought 200 shares
of Central Airlines
at $2.25 for $450.
And I met the Chief
Executive Officer,
whose name was Lamar Muse.
And they came over to my
parents' house one time
and had dinner.
And my mother's dog bit
his wife on the nose.
[LAUGHTER]
They didn't leave, but
it went to show you
he was a good sport
and resilient.
So that was something
kind of funny.
But anyway, the stock went up.
It was acquired about a year
and a half later by Frontier
Airlines for $14 a share.
So $2.25 turned into
$14 pretty quickly.
And I just thought,
this beats sitting out
in the sun carrying
forms around.
And I was hooked for life.
And that was a good
success to start with.
I had a lot of
failures after that.
But I kind of figured
it all out eventually.
Maybe I have, I don't know.
We'll see.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Wow.
So did you start
investing right away, or--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Well, I bought a little.
So I'd hear something,
and I'd buy stock,
and just hearing
something about a stock
isn't a very good
investment system,
because you hear it from
people who don't know
what they're talking about.
It took a while to figure out
who did know what they were
talking about and who didn't.
But I'm always fascinated by
it and always interested in it.
And you know, I kid
around about myself,
but my wife took me to
this event every year
called "Art About Town."
And you would bid
on paintings, and I
would bid on paintings
for less than I
figured the frame value was.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Less
than the frame value?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Less than the frame value,
because I was a value investor.
And so people would say, well,
did you make money doing it?
I said, no, I never
recognized a penny--
they're all horrible.
But at least, I had
some cheap frames.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Wow.
Shad, I think somewhere
in the mid '70s,
you also started a banking or
a brokerage operation, right?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
I worked for this firm called
Schneider, Bernet & Hickman.
And I was a Syndicate Manager.
I would bid the new issues.
I would look at the
new issues and try
to get the firm into the deals.
And then I left
there, and you know,
I wanted to start
my own firm, which
I called Rowe and Company,
Investment Bankers/Brokers.
We really were just
a brokerage firm
and did a little investment
banking, but not much.
And then I did that and
traded for the firm's account
and made a little money.
And then in 1985, I
decided to start a fund
to share the joys of
short selling, which
I was doing a lot of,
because the skyline in Dallas
was just pure cranes--
like it is here, now.
But you know, there were
see-through buildings
everywhere, and I
figured somebody bad was
going to happen, so I
started short selling.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Were you short selling
stocks or real estate?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, stocks--
bank stocks, real estate stocks,
real estate-related stocks.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: What
was the thesis, there?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: The thesis
was it was terribly
overbuilt, and everyone
was going go broke, which
I was absolutely right on.
And they did.
And so I wouldn't
say that was fun,
but it was good to be right.
In fact, if I'd saved
my money and waited
until things really
broke down, I
could have made some great buys.
And it just shows how every
dark cloud has a silver lining
kind of deal.
So I could've done--
it's just a matter of which
side you're looking at it.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Do you think getting
the timing right was important
with the short selling?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Of course it was, sure.
And you know, you know
what I found out was that--
if you buy stock, and it goes
down, the most you can lose
is the money that you put up.
And as it goes down some more,
you have a smaller problem,
and you don't worry about.
But if you short a
stock, and it goes up--
you're just sick, you
can't even breathe,
because you can have
unlimited loss potential-- you
could die and be incapacitated
and lose every dime you have.
There's an overpriced stock
service I took for a while--
late '80s-- and they
recommended shorting Microsoft.
And every couple of
months, they'd say,
hold for a better exit point.
Well, hell, they
lost all their money.
So it's not a good
solid business,
and when I was doing it,
interest rates were high,
real rates were high,
and broker's call
was about where the prime was.
So if you put up treasury
bills and then shorted stock,
you'd get a broker's call
on the short position, which
would mean that you'd be
up 15% when you started,
and it was pretty good.
And now, of course, you
have to pay to borrow them,
so you're down when
you start, so there's
a big difference, there.
I didn't figure that
out until later,
but that's why it
was attractive.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Right,
and taxes also were--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Oh,
taxes were also the same.
There were the same
taxes on dividends
and interest and short sales,
and short-swing profits
and long-term profits.
Everything was taxed the
same, so it didn't matter.
And so that was another
little added factor.
Plus, you really
never had to cover.
You could take the money
and pair the trades off,
you know what I mean--
cover it versus the
box, which would
mean you could
buy it back-- hold
a long position and short
position, all at $0.25 a share
or something.
You'd never have to
pay taxes for it.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Could you explain
that a little bit, Shad, for us?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Sure.
You know, if you're shorting
versus the box of stock,
you would borrow the
shares that you had bought
and deliver them against
your short position
or hold them against
your short position.
So you would have covered,
but not recovered.
But everything would
be blocked out,
and you could just
keep the tax money.
And then that was outlawed
in the Tax Rule of 1985.
But that made it a little
bit better business then.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So you
were getting paid to borrow,
the taxes were
favorable, and the market
was not fairly valued
according to that.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: No, and
there was a lot more retail
investing then than there
was the last few years.
So not as smart.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So why
did you give up short selling?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
it becomes all-consuming.
You know, you'd think you'd
feel better about it as you
get older, but it hurts worse.
And my mother,
typically, would just
always try to be
optimistic about things,
and one time, she said--
Shaddie, don't worry, I'm sure
something terrible will happen.
[LAUGHTER]
And that didn't make
me feel any better,
but that was sort of the idea.
You know, you were looking
for bad outcomes all the time,
which, you know,
it's a happier life,
if you're looking
for good outcomes.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: And so
after you gave up short selling,
you moved on to finding small,
local companies in Texas.
Can you talk to us a
little bit about that?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, actually,
in the time between
Central Airlines--
I also owned small companies,
I owned Southwest Airlines
when they had three and
then four airplanes--
so I knew something about
the airline business,
and I knew something
about advertising business
a little bit,
because of my father.
And so I was sort of set up--
I owned some things
on those lines.
And I find that one kind
of door leads to another,
and everything is
kind of connected.
We're all connected.
And so, between my father--
and you know, who I'm much
more friendly toward now
than I was when he was
alive, unfortunately--
but you could kind of get a
feel for different businesses.
So in the end, the shorts would
eventually turned into longs.
I bought back-- I
owned-- it was short--
WPP Group in 1991, and
then covered in '92
and covered in '91 and
then ended up buying it
and made a lot on it.
And Southwest Airlines,
I did very well on.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
So when did you
buy your first shares
of Southwest Airlines?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: About 1974.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: 1974?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: That's about--
I still have some.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: You
still have the same shares--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: No,
no, not the same shares.
I sold most of it, but the
stuff is very valuable.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Wow.
Would you know how much the
revenues have compounded by
or the stock price
has compounded
by since you bought it?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Oh, it was probably 27%.
It was huge.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
20% over 30+ years.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yes.
It's amazing what it did.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: What
was it about how Southwest
that got your attention?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Well, Lamar Muse.
He's the same guy that was
the head of Central Airlines.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Right.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: And
so I felt like I knew him.
And it was obvious to me that
they were doing something
better, faster, cheaper.
They were flying between Dallas
and San Antonio and Houston
on a tight schedule and
doing it for not much
than the price of a bus ticket.
So the traffic was expanding.
They were stimulating the
market, and it was growing.
And they did that
everywhere they went
all over the United States.
And now, they've gone abroad.
And you know, it's
a better story.
They have one airplane
that they fly.
They just threw an
engine out, I saw.
It was on the news, today.
But it was just a once in
a lifetime kind of deal.
And to do it in an
airline is very unusual,
because really it never has
shown loss in all these years.
And other ones went
broke all the time.
But they didn't put
their customers first.
They put themselves first.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: And
their employees, too.
They treat--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah,
they treat everybody well.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
--very well, yeah.
So around 15 years ago, maybe,
or a little older than that,
you changed your outlook again--
focusing on companies
that can scale--
do things faster, better,
cheaper for the customers.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: How did
this change happen, and maybe,
give us some examples?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
it was part of an odd man
out kind of thing.
You know, if you own
stock in a company,
you're kind of second rate
compared to the management.
You know, they don't
always tell you the truth,
and they're manipulating you.
But if you think the company
is really doing something
for the stakeholders, for the
shareholders, for the customers
than for themselves, you
feel a lot better about it.
So I feel better as an
investor if I've invested
in a company like that.
So better, faster,
cheaper, and for-- and
not to-- the customer, and to
the delight of the customer.
And be on a scale
that if it works in--
oh, and another
thing in advertising,
I did-- this WPP Group
I talked to you about,
where Martin Sorrell
just left, he got fired.
But he said that the
word globalization
is a misnomer, that the better
word is Americanization.
People all over the world really
want to live the way we do,
here.
I don't know whether
you believe that.
I think there's something to it.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Yeah.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: So
if it's a success here,
it can be a success elsewhere.
And that's certainly
been the case of airlines
and of Starbucks,
Amazon-- you know,
all these companies operate
throughout the world.
And you know, you used to talk
about the law of large numbers.
Well, hell, you need
to own a stock that
has a large number,
because there
are a large number of
people in the world
and a large number of
square miles to cover,
and you've got to get out there
before someone beats you to it.
I think these big companies
have a huge advantage, now.
Rather than big, cumbersome
oafs, like they used to be,
they're really big and
strong and powerful,
and they just win-win-win.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
following up on that, Shad,
recently I think you
wrote about the necessity
of large numbers--
that large numbers are not
just needed to compete,
but to actually succeed.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Right.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
So can you talk to us
a little bit about that?
Why do you think large
numbers are a necessity?
And maybe give us an example
of a company that you think
has efficiency going for it?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: We can't
talk about Google, can we?
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Uh.
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: I'm teasing.
Well, all of them, really.
You know, Southwest Airlines
now is going to Mexico.
They're going in the Caribbean.
They're big enough
to do it, and no one
would sit aside
and let Southwest
do to them what they did.
I mean, Southwest, I think
couldn't happen again,
because people are just smarter.
I think that board
compositions have changed.
I think the people
are more attentive.
And you know, the kind of
dull, kind of half senile Chief
Executive Officer who sits
there and acts like a dictator--
they're over.
And women on the boards
have helped, I think.
And there is just
more visibility,
and it's hard to be as
secretive as people used to be.
I think that
governance is better,
and I think the opportunities
are better perceived.
And investors
aren't any smarter,
but I think the whole investment
situation has improved.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: And
I think you also stressed
on efficiency, right, Shad?
And you say that Costco is not
just efficient, but elegant.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Oh yeah, it's great.
It's fun to be there,
fun to shop there.
You save money.
You get great products,
you get great value.
You see the same people there.
And I think the shopping
is sort of an adventure.
It's kind of fun.
And they put things in the
store just to get you back.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: How
did you approach Costco
as an investment decision?
Did you--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Well, I liked going there.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: OK.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: It's
probably as simple as that.
I thought, if I like it,
other people probably like it,
and they do.
You want to save money,
you want to get value--
you don't care about
the brand name.
I mean, the brand-- what
is it, Kingwood, is it?
It's great stuff.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
The Kirkland?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Kirkland.
Well, I'm losing my
mind, here, but yeah.
It's really good.
I like everything about it.
One time, I was at
this investment group,
and the deal on the
dinner we were going to
was that the person who had
the worst bottle of wine
had to buy dinner.
And so I went, and I
took a bottle of wine
that my wife had picked out
from Constellation Brands.
I can't remember the
name of it, but it
was a 92 on the wine or
whatever board, or something.
But anyway, I heard the
waitress complaining and saying,
this wine is flawed,
the cork is no good.
And then they didn't put
wrap it up in tin foil,
so I know what it is.
I said, all right, I give
up-- it's me, I'll buy dinner.
And I wrote a letter
to Jim Sinegal,
saying that I'd had this
horrible experience.
And by golly,
Constellation Brands
sent me a gift
certificate for Costco
to give me my money back.
You know, I just made
a huge profit on it
and bought more stock.
And then I did the same thing
to McDonald's and talked
about something terrible
that happened there.
And I got a form letter back--
sorry for your bad
experience and just nothing.
But you know, that's sort
of a heroic response--
just going overboard,
bending over backwards
to make people happy.
And if the customer comes
first, you get ahead.
And if it doesn't,
you get behind.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
I think when you said--
customer comes
first, I'm reminded
of another one of your
nice characterizations
about stage one companies,
stage two companies,
and stage three companies.
And these aren't to do
with size of the company
or age of the company.
They're with how the company--
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: How they act.
In stage one-- everything's
new-- you're doing something
better, faster, cheaper
for the customer.
Your stock is soaring.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Can you
give us examples of each stage?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well, any
little company that takes off.
Southwest Airlines has been kind
of stage one the whole career
it's had.
And stage two is maybe
like a Starbucks,
where they start selling
tea and different food
and trying to get more
money from the same person.
And stage three is most airlines
and banks and everything else,
where there's no question
they're out to get you.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
So how do you
detect this change between
stage two and stage three, Shad?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well, I'm
a customer, just like you are.
It's obvious, isn't it?
That's what I think.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So what
are the hallmarks, Shad,
of a great business?
Like, these stage two,
stage one kind of business--
what are the hallmarks?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, I would
love to find a business that was
doing something better, faster,
cheaper on a scale that
could be taken globally,
that I'd seen it work in
the United States, that
had great management.
You know, I don't know
how you define that,
but you know it when you see it.
And some valuation that somehow
you could think was reasonable.
And that sounded like that--
I was laughing the other day
about that David Allan Coe
song.
You know, what was it--
I think your song is perfect,
but you haven't said anything
about mama or trains or being
drunk or falling off the bus--
but all the
ingredients are there,
just like the ingredients are
there for a perfect stock.
And you're always looking
for the perfect stock.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Do you do you
focus on capital
intensivity at all, when
you look at a great company?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Capital
intensiv-- capital what?
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Capital intensiveness--
how they use their
balance sheet.
Are those things you look at?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Well, I look at it.
But I presume they
know more than I do,
so I'm not too
judgmental about it.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: OK.
So let's invert
that a little bit.
You know, like Carl
Jacobi and Charlie Munger.
So what are some things you
want to avoid in a business?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
If you were still short,
I'd want the same thing.
You know, if it's not doing
better, faster, cheaper,
it's doing something worse.
It irritates people.
They don't like it, and
business is going down.
And it has no
potential overseas,
because it has no potential
in the United States.
You'd invert it, and it
would be perfect inversion.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Are
there industries or sectors
that you would avoid?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
I don't think that way.
I think of the ones that
I would be attracted to.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: OK.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
And clearly, technology
is an area--
home building is
kind of interesting,
because all the Millennials
are living at home,
and their parents are
getting tired of them.
And I think they'll buy
houses at some point.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Technology
and home building are sectors--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah,
kind of the whole modern home,
you know, the smart home.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Right.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: So
I know this guy that runs
a [? Pull-T-- ?]
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
[? Pull-T ?] group, yes.
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Yeah, and then I
don't think it matters
too much, but they're all
going to have it, when
the technology finally
brought in house to--
bring the house
into the modern age.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: If it can
continue on another Charlie
Munger-ism--
we learn more from our
mistakes than our successes.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: I
oughta know a lot, then.
[LAUGHTER]
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
after short selling,
you know, once you
moved to being a long
and being a consumer
focused investor,
what are one or two
mistakes you've made
that you want to talk about?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: One of those,
I don't want to talk about.
And the smaller companies--
there was a company in Dallas
called Employers Casualty
Insurance Company that
did workers compensation.
And it was a cheap, cheap stock.
And it had always
been a great company
and had a great balance sheet.
And the management
wouldn't talk to me.
And I presumed that meant
that it was so good,
they didn't want to
share the information.
And so I bought it.
And they wouldn't return the
phone call, and it went broke.
That's a bad example, or
a good example of that.
Another one-- you know, I had
some success with Southwest
Airlines several times.
And I got very interested
in Greyhound buses.
And even my wife said, what
are you thinking about--
no one rides a bus.
And you couldn't
see that no one was
on the buses, because
the windows were tinted.
So that was a painful one.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
you probably picked up
a lot of trading techniques as a
short seller, looking at price,
volume, maybe margin
calls, technicals.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: No.
I didn't learn anything.
[LAUGHTER]
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
So do you look
at anything other
than the customer
experience and fundamentals
when you invest in a business?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, it's
nice if the stock is off
for the wrong reason.
That's always a good one.
They're panicked
about something--
the shareholders
are panicked over
something they shouldn't
be panicked over.
That's a good reason to do it.
You get a better
bargain that way.
But I think in the
long term, it doesn't
make that much difference
when you buy it,
if you buy the right company.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So let's
focus on that a little bit--
the valuation, right.
How do you approach
valuation when
deciding to buy a business?
What is an upper bound
you're willing to pay?
How do you arrive at that?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, I'd just
want to see how you can pay
10 times what you thought it
was eventually going to earn.
That would be OK with me, if
you had a pretty high degree
of confidence in it.
Because with interest
rates where they are,
you've got to think what
you can do with your money.
And if people say,
well, the market
is very overpriced,
and the NASDAQ
sells at 33 times earnings
or whatever it sells at--
well, you know, what's the
yield on a 10-year government?
3%-- that's 33 times earnings.
And that's the most
they're going to earn.
So the companies have a
chance to earn a lot more.
So I think stocks are
probably cheap relative
to your choices of what
you can do with the money.
Real estate isn't any better.
Farming-- well, I don't know
what you're going to do.
But your choices are limited.
You know, stock is people,
it's real estate, it's capital,
it's machines.
It's being put together
by smart people,
working and creating
value and growing--
pretty exciting.
And it doesn't excite people
very much, now, but it will.
They haven't thought it through.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So once
you buy a stock, ideally, Shad,
you never want to sell it.
You write fairly well that
selling creates two problems,
right?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Right.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: The tax
problem, and the problem when--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Then you pay taxes,
and you've got to
replace the investment.
You've got to be right twice.
All you've got to do
on a real growth cycle
is to be right once.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
But sometimes you
still have to sell, Shad.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Sure.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: And do
you sell because the situation
changes, or do you sell also
sometimes because the price
runs up too much?
How do you think of it?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
I've done a little bit of that.
You know, this WPP Group,
which I bought years ago--
I sold some in 2000.
It was selling at a crazy price,
and didn't get it all sold,
but I kept it.
And then you know I knew
Martin Sorrell and watched him.
But then I watched
other companies
come along, like this one.
And you know, it was hurting
their business very badly.
So I eventually sold it.
And I made good sales, too.
That would be a
reason-- you know,
if the business is
fundamentally changed
by technology or by something
that they haven't done.
That would be the reason to sell
it, or the management's bad,
or something had changed
that you could see.
But not because it didn't show
relative strength or something
crazy like that.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Shad, if we
can shift gears a little bit,
you've spoken about the
need for pension funds
to be simple in their
investing process.
And recently, there
have been incidents
of funds that have invested
in exotic foreign agriculture
and things that
didn't work out well.
Why do you think this
happens, and what
can be done to improve this?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: If you'll
think of yourself as a stock,
I think it helps.
You know, you have more money
coming in than going out,
hopefully, and you all are
in there to buy stocks,
and your estate grows.
And you get a better job or
you don't get a better job,
but you're spending
less than you're saving,
then you're grow up and you're
going to be rich old guy
or girl or whatever.
And that's the way it works.
And these pension
funds have more money
going out than coming in.
And compound interest is the
eighth wonder of the world,
but when it's working against
you, you can't beat it.
That's what's happening
in these pension funds--
they promise more
than they can deliver.
And so they're saying
they're making money--
or they're only 75% funded,
or something like that.
But really, they're
going to go broke.
And you can be an
alarmist about it.
I got fired--
I was the Chairman of
the Texas Review Board
for 12 years or something.
And you know, Governor
Perry finally fired me.
He got tired of listening,
tired of hearing me.
But compound interest
is a wonderful thing
to have on your side
and a terrible thing
to have working against you.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Do you think that's
likely to change in the
coming years, the way--
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Oh, sure, it'll
change-- like, the sun will
come up in the west or the east
or wherever it does.
You know, no.
They're immutable laws.
It isn't going to change.
Behavior isn't going to change.
People get hold of
other people's money.
They like it.
It gives them power, and
they want to be smart.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
Shad, one of the books,
I think, that have
really influenced
you has been "Money
Masters," by John Train.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: What
about the book influenced you?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
he's a good money manager.
And he understood
the distinctions
that investors were
making in their minds.
It's just a good survey.
And nothing's
changed since then.
No one had ever studied
investment managers before.
They were just kind of
like clerks, or something.
Then they became kind of
larger than life, sometimes,
and it became
interesting to people.
But the thing I
found interesting--
he's very thoughtful,
and one time I said,
after studying
all these people--
value investors
and all this-- how
did you become a
growth stock manager,
at, like, T. Rowe Price?
And he said that value
investors are really
kind of glorified accountants.
They're looking at the gap
between their perceived value
and what the assets
are going to be worth
and its market
capitalization and trying
to close the difference.
And then when they
do it, they've
got to go buy something else.
So it's a constant
turnover process.
If you ever make a mistake,
you pay a lot of taxes,
and you've lost all your money.
But a growth stock
investor, which, he said--
that suited his nature--
you're really kind
of a futurologist--
looking in the future and
trying to figure out what's
going to happen.
He said that suited his
nature, so that's what he did.
That makes perfect sense to me.
And it requires fewer
people, and you just
have to be right a couple
of times in your life.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: When
we were speaking earlier
with one of your
colleagues, [INAUDIBLE],,
you spoke about the
spectrum of investors--
short sellers, activists,
long only investors.
Do you want to
share that with us?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: I was just
saying that short sellers really
think that they're the smartest
people on Earth,
that they're much
smarter than these managements.
And they're so smart, they'll
risk their whole stash
to prove they're right.
And they either go broke
or have nervous breakdowns
or just shoot themselves.
I mean, I know a guy who
tried to just killed himself.
But it's a terrible life.
And then the next ones are the
activist investors-- activists.
They think they're smarter
than management, too.
They're going to tell
them how to do it.
So they just get in
there and start saying,
do this, do this, do that.
And we want to sell the company
and want to make these fees.
And then--
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
The value investors.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: And
then the value investors I've
already talked about.
You can rank them all.
And then the growth stock
investors just think--
this company is
smarter than I am,
they know the business
better than I do,
plus it's a great business.
And it if isn't,
I'll get out of it.
That's how you have a
slight advantage, there.
You want to put yourself
on the side where you have
an advantage, and they don't.
So if you perceive that
there's a long term
future for the business--
they're doing simply
better, faster, cheaper
and for the customer, you can
buy it at a reasonable price,
and if you're wrong,
you can sell it--
that's a pretty good deal.
And that's one I
think I want to take.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So Shad, I
want to get a little personal
with this question for you.
So around two decades ago,
you were diagnosed with
Parkinson's.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
Shortly afterwards you
considered shutting
down your fund.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: But then
you chose not to shut it down.
Maybe you should
walk us through that.
And also, after
that, you've stated
that having Parkinson's
has actually
made you a better person.
Can you talk to us--
why you feel that?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Well, Michael J. Fox,
I'm on his board.
He calls up-- Parkinson's is
a gift that keeps on taking.
But I think it makes you
a little humble and more
appreciative of what you
did have going right.
You have to make
adjustments to it.
But my first reaction was what
the hell is going on here?
And I thought, well,
I'll do everybody a favor
and shut the fund down.
And I gave all the money back.
I had some stocks that
were hard to get out
of-- they were illiquid.
And so I dragged my
feet and then decided--
what else am I going to do?
So I changed my mind and have
had a good record ever since.
I had a good record
the whole time,
but yeah, it changes
your life a little bit.
And you appreciate the
things that go your way,
and the things that
don't, you don't
worry as much about,
which is meaning to say--
I'm kind of a completely
pleasant personality-- is not.
But you know, I think investing
is a matter of finding out
who you are and where
you fit in the world
and how it all fits together.
You know, I don't know
whose saying it is,
but-- if you don't
know who you are,
the stock market is an
expensive place to find out--
is true.
But if you fit your nature
with your investment style,
and it makes economic sense,
you can probably do pretty well.
If you think of
yourself as a stock--
where you have more
coming in than going out--
and so you're doing
something with the money--
in other words, you're
managing your cash flow--
you're going to end up
being a rich old guy or girl
or whatever.
And that makes sense to me.
So I feel like the
game is going my way.
And I feel like that's
the way anybody who
thought about it should go.
And if you listen
to the television--
the stocks are
under accumulation,
it's breaking out, it's breaking
down, it's lacking support--
I'm selling, I'm selling,
buy-sell, buy-sell.
Just pay a lot of commissions
and dealer spreads
and lose your money
and talk more.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: So
Shad, before we open it up
to the audience for
questions, I want
to ask you one question
that we ask all our guests.
What is some advice you would
give the personal investor,
someone who's starting their
journey today, maybe investing
their first few dollars and
trying to make compounding
work for them?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
I'd say the same thing--
who are you, what do you like?
You know, are you a
cheerleader, or are you a booer?
Do you know you want
the home team to win,
or do you want the
home team to lose?
And pick companies you like--
you like the
management, you think
they have a bright future,
you like dealing with them,
you think they're good people,
and just sit on it and own it.
And think of yourself as a
partial owner of a business,
just like you're the owner of
your entire business, which
is your life.
So that's kind of
Warren Buffett 101,
combined with a little pop
psychology and my experience.
And that's what I would do.
That's what I'm trying to do.
Does that makes sense?
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Yeah.
No, thank you, Shad.
Thank you so much for that.
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Fun being here.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: I
think we'll open it up
to audience questions.
And I have a few more
in case we have time
at the end of
audience questions.
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: All right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
That's very inspiring.
So I have a question about the
large number as a necessity.
I was wondering if you
think there is the risk
of the anti-trust once
the company goes large,
and the large member goes--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Sure.
That's a terrifying
aspect of it.
But usually the
litigation starts
coming when they're trying
to use the government
to protect themselves from
competition or something.
So I don't know.
It'll be interesting.
I watched another
company the other day,
talking on the television
about its issues and problems.
But I think that these
congressmen and these state
legislators, they're so busy
that they don't have time
to understand
anything very clearly.
And you know, if the
business is still good,
and will probably
survive and do fine.
And they have
constituencies that--
people vote, and so I don't
worry about it too much.
I'm worried about it
some, but not too much.
I think it's overrated.
Does that makes sense?
That answers your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it makes sense.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
better, faster, cheaper.
What is one business that's
better, faster, cheaper
that you would like to own,
but you don't because of price
or whatever other reason?
And I have a second
part question.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: I
don't have any of those.
I bought them.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: What is
something that you
owned in the past that is
no longer, better, faster,
cheaper, and why?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Well, let's see--
McDonald's.
And you know, they're getting
beaten by lots of people, now.
And PetSmart, which
has started selling
very expensive products.
You save money-- put your dog
up at the warehouse stores,
and put them down and add
more functions in them.
But it was not as
good a company--
what they could do to
the dog or do to you
or how they could trick you.
But really, I'm just trying
to find the ones that are good
and hold them.
I sold WPP, which--
I don't know, what
I made, 33 times
on my money-- and the
reason was the competitors,
online competitors were
doing it better, faster,
cheaper, and getting
more for the money.
And you watch regular
television, now, and the ads
on it for drugs that--
you know, the side effects
might be that you'll
die, crying for your mother.
They're just
terrible, off-putting.
And so, an ad that
applies to you directly--
that you and you only see--
that's structured, that
will tell you something
that you want to hear seems
like a better deal to me.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
I think you had also
written about CarMax,
which, back in the day,
was excellent pricing, right?
But with discoverability, now--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Yeah, the advantage
is gone, because everybody
knows what everybody paid
for everything.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: Because of
internet and Kelley Blue Book.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
We had Mr. Schwab visit us,
I think, about two years ago,
from Charles Schwab.
And he talked about
how, in his words--
Charles Schwab
continues to deliver
their services to
their customers
better, faster, cheaper.
How do you think about Charles
Schwab, say, compared to,
say T. Rowe, which you do on?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
Compared to T. Rowe?
PRANESH SRINIVASAN:
T. Rowe, yeah.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: I
got a good price on T. Rowe.
I'm really to get out of it.
AUDIENCE: Do you think Charles
Schwab does better, faster,
cheaper?
You are in that
industry, so probably you
know better about who does?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
I think that right now T. Rowe
Price probably does
better, because they're
focused on growth companies.
And the market isn't
paying the premium
that its certainly capable of
paying for those companies.
I can remember-- I was not in
the market at that time, but--
the Nifty 50 were induplicable
companies that would always
be in people's
portfolios, regardless,
and had always
grown to-- they all
sold at 100 times
earnings, 1973.
So I think that sort of
thing can happen again--
maybe have a World
50, World Nifty 50.
You know, you talk
about Bitcoin--
well, hell, Coca Cola stock
used to be like Bitcoin.
Or the technology
companies are like that.
I think that could
easily happen.
And I think that these
companies can make the--
you know, they know more about
their businesses than I do,
and they can buy them for
stock or buy them for cash,
and everybody turns into
a Warren Buffett, kind of.
I mean, what did we learn
from Warren Buffett.
I mean, he started out with,
you know, delivering papers
and turned that into
becoming the richest
guy in the world for a while.
And what did he do-- he just
had an obsession with money
and never spent it,
and just compounded,
compounded, compounded.
AUDIENCE: I always wonder
about nonprofit investments.
And when I think of
Buffett or Gates and a lot
of philanthropic
investments, you
know-- is it in the
context of philanthropy
versus giving away.
What's this actual investment
and being able to manage it?
And I always wondered
what the thought process
is when the rich decide to
go one way or the other.
And I'm just curious
to hear your thoughts.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
On accumulating money?
AUDIENCE: Philanthropy,
or you know,
investment in change in the
context of larger good--
how do investors think about it?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: I
think about it all the time.
And I don't--
I'm usually disappointed by
what I discover about what
was really happening.
I mean, you know people
get old, and they
want to have hospitals
named after them,
and they want to
invest in health care.
And the health care people are
just charging more every year.
And it's become
too big a burden.
Not to complain about it, but
yeah, I think it's an issue.
You know, you don't want
to die with all your money.
And you'd rather have you
decide what to do with it
than let someone else
decide what to do with it.
Certainly.
any one is going to do better
than the government, probably.
But I think it's a big issue.
We don't live forever,
because we all think we will.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wonder what's your advice
about risk controlling
for personal investors who don't
have much time to investigate
what's going on in the market.
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Well, you'd
beat 90% of the
investors, if you just
bought the S&P 500 index
from Vanguard or Fidelity
or something like that.
That's what most
people ought to do,
then they wouldn't worry about
what the individual stocks are.
You know, you put 90% of your
money in those index funds
and then play with other money,
just like your play money
and have fun with it.
I mean-- my advice.
AUDIENCE: I really
enjoy your sort
of three stage model
on how companies
sort of get fat and then
get lazy and then, you know,
get eaten.
One question I have
is how frequently
do companies that
you've purchased
turn into a different stage?
Or obviously, you're
trying to buy ones
that always stay in stage one.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE:
That's very hard to do.
AUDIENCE: --worse case--
end up in stage two, but--
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Because they're
successful in stage one,
and that leads to problems.
Just like with people.
It's just exactly like a person.
And you know, at some point,
the company is successful,
and it wants to
do something else.
And the individual wants
to do something else that
didn't make them the
money in the first place.
And this is exactly
the same thing.
So you want to make enough
money so that your comfortable
and you get your needs taken
care of, but that's enough,
probably, unless it becomes
a game or an obsession.
But you're right, exactly.
It is the same thing
as with a person.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask you a
brief follow-up, which is--
in a profile of
you from 2016, you
mention that you aim
to have about 15 stocks
in your portfolio
at any given time,
and you sort of sell off the
worst performing one every year
and try to replace it.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that
incidentally you also
mention that by concentration,
only about six of them
make up about 70% of the
actual portfolio by value.
Is that a fairly constant
sort of performance metric?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
it just is what happens.
This is what happened to me.
But I'd like to--
I'm probably at about 12
or 13 stocks, at most.
And most of the money
is in very few stocks.
But you want to be
diversified to the point
that you've got the odds in
your favor, but not to the point
that you don't
keep up with them.
And I'm being a little bit
more disciplined about it
than I used to be, but
it's hard to sell a stock
once you have a profit in it.
It's hard to sell it, pay the
taxes, make up the net worth,
and pay the dealer spread
and make the money back.
So what you tend to do is
own some other companies
at low cost.
But you know, if you
want to step out,
you've got to sell them.
And they've got to fit what
you really think is happening.
I mean, I was saying the
same thing 10 years ago,
but my portfolio has completely
turned over since then.
And the reason is I have
better companies now, I think--
knock wood.
AUDIENCE: As companies grow,
the culture is very difficult
to maintain, right?
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: What is?
AUDIENCE: Especially when
bureaucracy creeps in.
What made you believe that
Southwest will continue keeping
its culture in the future?
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Its culture?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Well,
they've got a good guy--
Gary Kelly, who's running it.
They've always had good
Chief Executive Officers.
But it's hard to change
a culture for the worse,
and it's hard to
change for the better.
And you know, I like to
pick on American Airlines,
but it just seems like they
invariably do the exact thing
that I don't want them to do--
like, changing a reservation.
Southwest, they let
you change your time.
American Airlines-- you
have to buy another ticket.
By the time they
tag their penalties
and everything else
on you, it was stupid.
I don't understand it.
And so who is your
fidelity owed to?
It's owed to your customer
and to the shareholders.
You know, you've got
stakeholders in any business,
and you've got to
treat them right.
And a lot of times these
professional managements
get hold of these
companies, and they think
they're the ones to be served--
they need to serve
themselves first.
And everybody can see that,
and they react against it.
And they don't share
in the business
and they go on, which
is fine, I guess.
It makes plenty of money.
But it could have made
more and had more fun
and contributed to
society, rather than not.
AUDIENCE: If I may
ask another question--
I understand that
for a short seller,
it's hard also because
you not only need
to get your decisions
right, you also
need to get your timing right.
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: Right.
AUDIENCE: As a value
investor, you know, I
guess you're not supposed
to time the market.
And we know, it's very hard.
But I keep wondering, because
for example, as of right now,
we are in, like, a
late part of the cycle.
I wonder, being
understanding and we
should not timing the market--
one, if there is a
strategy you think you
master would deal
slightly differently
than the beginning of the cycle?
I don't know-- it's kind of a--
FREDERICK "SHAD" ROWE: I'm
glad to know that we're
at the end of the cycle.
I found that our from you.
I don't know that we are at all.
I don't have any idea.
I think that from the time
I've been in the business,
the general public's attitude
is much less interested
in the stock market.
And there are fewer
shares or fewer companies
that are public.
There are better
companies, now--
they're better run.
And it's just as competitive,
and they make more money.
The profitability is higher.
I think stocks are a heck of
a deal relative to what else
you can do with your money.
And if you get a few of those
other things right-- you know,
the better, faster, cheaper
and for the customer
and to the delight
of the customer,
and if it works in the United
States and can be taken
internationally--
I don't see how you miss.
And when you find
out, I hope you'll
call me and tell me about it.
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: All right.
I think we are out of time.
Thank you so much, Shad, for--
FREDERICK "SHAD"
ROWE: Is that OK?
PRANESH SRINIVASAN: --coming
and speaking with us.
I think we should all--
really enjoyed it.
[APPLAUSE]